let's talk about why call of duty should
be afraid of battlefield again this year
now a year ago this would have been
crazy talk modern warfare was doing
fantastic battlefield had drifted off
those fans had gone over to call of duty
but now call of duty is kind of a mess
after the cold war integration
and to make matters even more
interesting dice la is
probably involved in the next
battlefield game which is headed up by
vince zampella who founded call of duty
i'm here joined by richie bracamonte and
we're going to talk over what could be
happening this year with the two
franchises
who's probably developing them and why
call of duty really should be concerned
again
as always if you guys love to talk about
call of duty like we do give us a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel
alright richie so what do we know so far
about later this year
aaron it's rumored so far that
sledgehammer games will take on call of
duty 2021
uh they're also according to some
reports they were
supposed to take on the game for 2020
but treyarch ended up doing that and we
all think it's because of the success of
the modern warfare reboot
after that happened and did so well they
probably wanted to see the success of
the black ops like revival happen so
they put treyarch in the driver's seat
and we got cold war this year so for
sledgehammer it sounds like
it's their turn in the cycle uh they got
kicked off last time and now it's their
time to shine
so why would that be exciting if
sledgehammer is the studio that takes
over the next call of duty game
it's exciting because well for me
personally i can speak to that because
i like all the games they've worked on
they got their start with helping out
with modern warfare 3
then they went on to do advanced warfare
and then world war ii
so their track record is pretty short
but it's growing and
it's a solid track record so far so
myself and i know of a few others
quite a few others who are excited to
see them take the director's chair and
make call of duty 2021 for this year
okay so that's why you're
hopeful about if sledgehammer games
heads the next call of duty
what are some of the pitfalls in
disasters we've seen recently that might
allow battlefield to
you know take back their fans from this
franchise
right we've uh we've definitely talked
about the integration of cold war and
war zone put together how they're
scooting away modern warfare we all know
that
although that's getting better and the
gun meta which is really crucial
is finally ironing out a lot of things
they're doing things right
but cold war the overall reception as
far as i can tell
in multiplayer with the exception of
zombies is a little dry
a lot of people including some of our
user comments talk about how they just
dropped off the game it's feeling pretty
samey and even though there are some
upgrades coming up some updates with
season two
that might pull people back but for the
most part a lot of people are falling
off of cold war
faster than a lot faster than modern
warfare 2019 in warzone
so that brings us to battlefield aaron
what are you hopeful for this uh this
new announcement this 2021 battlefield
so there's two really important things
to talk about here
one of them is the studio that's making
it and one of them is
and i think you know like one of the
more important things to tackle first is
why fans fell off of battlefield in the
first place
battlefield for a very long time like
bad company 2
battlefield 3 all those games were this
like
just beautiful sandbox and there was so
much freedom to it and players could
break it like when they made the mav
elevators or
you know they were they were just
running around screwing around with the
eod robot
the thing is is that you know starting
around battlefield 3
dice went in a very heavy visually
appealing direction they wanted to make
the game look better
but it was at the expense of a lot of
these a lot of the freedom of the game
that people
loved it was a combination of that like
battlefield 4 just started to feel a
little bit too much like battlefield 3
but then also they started going in this
infantry focused direction
and you know they went retro and
after a while it just sort of felt like
it was an infantry game
um i mean there were plenty there were
vehicle maps but not nearly as many
vehicle maps so call of duty just
does infantry warfare better and i think
people started falling off it at that
point
the retro theme also handicapped them
with things like customization
there's just way less customization when
you're talking about
world war one and world war ii it's just
kind of unfortunately part of the
the package that you signed up for that
brings us to the game that might be
coming out later this year
they're targeting late 2021 and we'll
just call it battlefield 6. so
i would be shocked if they don't turn
back to a modern setting they kind of
have to
they've played out the older settings at
this point and it's being developed by
dice la
now dice la handled a lot of their test
servers and to be just completely crude
about it
they're the studio that fixed
battlefield 4 so they
they learn from their mistakes about
what was wrong with battlefield 4 both
like technically and also level design
they've also you know helped with a
couple of dlcs dice la right now is
being led by
vince impella i want to say that we
don't know for sure that vince is
directly involved with the making of the
next battlefield game but vince
essentially
co-founded call of duty and what he is
really really good at
are honing gameplay mechanics until
they're perfect he's the guy that did
titanfall 1 and titanfall 2 which were
just absolutely sublime
shooter games does that mean you're
going to get you know call of duty in
your battlefield
i don't think so like you know again
assuming he's involved
he's a guy who's really good at looking
at what makes the game good
for example looking at the dark souls
mechanics and how he can apply that to
the star wars universe in jedi fallen
order so what he can offer is
the basics which is something that
battlefield was always really terrible
at
battlefield had an incredible sandbox
but they were terrible at things like
progression vehicle controls or just
sort of like
the way the the game generally played
when you weren't actually
shooting even just to switch your
loadouts between
games you had to go to a web browser to
do it i mean we're talking about like
really
stuff way behind for what it should have
been so vincent pelle is really good at
that stuff and even if he's not
directly involved in the day-to-day
making this game even if it's just
running through him i don't think he
would let that stuff
you know pass so i am really excited for
this
next battlefield game that being said
you know modern warfare is languishing
because activision really neglected it
um they
made this hard switch to cold war cold
war was probably being developed at the
same time through no fault of their own
and they
you know i'm speculating but they
probably didn't realize what they had in
modern warfare
so it's not entirely cold war's fault
but also like
you know they just recently dropped a
season two trailer and it looks like
they've kind of recognized
that they are not going to capitalize on
that milsim crowd that loved battlefield
and that loved modern warfare
they seem to be going full zombies this
time around which to their credit is
what they're good at
but i just don't see that pulling the
battlefield crowd
back in and i feel like that really
leaves an opening for another
battlefield game to come in again and
really take that crowd that got pulled
away by modern warfare
that's a really good point and something
i haven't really considered
treyarch and the black ops games start
off pretty humble but they get pretty
fantastical
fast like you think of the way black ops
4 ended
there was so much some fun skins they
got goofy kind of quick
as they always do so you're right about
the whole milsim thing and the whole
modern warfare 2019 vibe if they want
that there's a window open now
yeah call of duty has just broken off
and sailed in another direction this
season i mean come on like
there were dragons in the trailer why
the f not
why not already season two let's go i
mean it's
it looked fun but uh you're definitely
right about that point
of of of how dice has an opportunity
here to kind of just
bring it scale it down a little bit so
for this part of the video we're gonna
take a look back at some of the user
comments you guys left
whether it's excitement for battlefield
6 or
if you want to just talk some call of
duty we're here let's check it out
in the biggest battlefield 6 rumors
video questionable content said
playing call of duty just makes me miss
the age of great battlefield games the
destruction and bad company games are
more than spectacle they could be
tactical
yeah that's a great point and bad
company is also a good
comparison to call of duty because it's
the most sort of
destruction oriented but also console
oriented game that
battlefield ever makes so i think a lot
of us miss
bad company and would love to head back
in that direction i always thought it
was funny that
call of duty tried this out in ghosts
they had
small destructible set pieces but
i was talking about this with jake
decker our very own jake
and he said uh yeah they just sort of
would
blow up and then that was the end of
that it wasn't tactical at all
as much as it was cinematic in
multiplayer which was kind of weird
all right our next user flamma diddle
i'm getting so bored of cold war
seven days in and i just can't take it
anymore
i need new new yes
i feel that uh as much as i i liked it
at the launch
um so this is one of those call of
duty's for me personally where i play
for
you know a few matches see a specific
map and i'm like okay i'm done for the
night like that
that happens in every call of duty game
but i feel like it happens later in the
year so for cold war
it's a handful of maps where i'm like
you know what i think i'm good i think
i'm done playing for the day
and that's not a good sign they're
adding more and more maps but you know
it's it's just a weird vibe to have so
early in the year
it's also really important to point out
that cold war is just a different
audience it's a more classic audience
and i don't want to rag on that game
from other than from like a battlefield
perspective
because they're people who don't want
the modern warfare game they want
cold war cold war is that game that
they've always wanted so like you guys
are awesome
it's a good game for you and we're just
talking about this from a you know
pretty specific perspective
so from our nobody is happy with call of
duty video we got a comment from
don dodo who says everyone is unhappy
about their games what can you do to fix
it
activision we will make a new god
and that's really true because no matter
what you can't stop this train like
they're making one every year we even
had a poll on our face our facebook and
twitter about
how it should be handled like should
they break the yearly cycle
should they really focus on all the
problems that are currently going on
or should they just keep going every
year and
most for the most part our audience on
twitter said
we should break the yearly cycle like
give developers time to
breathe and come up with a like not such
a strict deadline come up with
more ideas that can be polished out
which i think is probably the most
important thing
we've seen how unpolished things have
kind of
have tanked call of duty sometimes but
it always comes back and it's always
here for another year for better or
worse
erin what do you think yeah pump the
bricks modern warfare felt more like a
platform like a fortnight or something
like that that they could have just kept
building on
and they will like they are going to
keep building on it they broke off
war zone which i'm never going to fully
acknowledge isn't modern warfare it's
totally modern warfare but
they're they're going to keep developing
that game
they don't need a call of duty every
year anymore i think a lot of people
feel that way
they just keep building on what you got
it's it's a great foundation you know
and and you won't run into these odd
situations too where you have um
oh call of duty on another engine trying
to cram itself onto
uh like a more modern engine you know
it's just it's awkward
since a call of duty comes out every
year it's prone to more of these weird
problems like crossgen and stuff so
that's something i haven't even
considered it's a good point i
personally would like to see
them pump the brakes also and just give
these developers more time i think
you know when when fans are starting to
be like i'm burned out on call of duty
every year like an iphone you know like
we don't get every iphone and
not all not all of us play every call of
duty so let's give them a break
and our next comment uh speaks to that
license to chill great name by the way
said cold war just feels old it's a step
back for the franchise in every way
yeah i mean that just kind of comes back
to i don't think it was their fault i
think they were developed at the same
time
but modern warfare just had a better
engine it is
it's one when you're playing cold war
even for the casual player you can
detect
like a big difference in gameplay and
you're right it's all it's the engine
it's something that
modern warfare spent like the whole year
perfecting
um it was a good launch out the gate but
that game only got better in my opinion
cold war
did feel like a step back unfortunately
all right so this is gonna be a good
year for shooter fans regardless i do
think
that call of duty should be concerned
about where battlefield is headed
but regardless if you're an old school
call of duty fan you have cold war
if you got sick of that you either have
a new call of duty game this year or you
have
battlefield to fall back on we're going
to learn a lot more about both of these
games probably fairly soon so again
battlefield in spring and classically
call of duty
in may or april so what are you guys
most excited for battlefield 6
more call of duty let us know in the
comments also be sure to check out our
call of duty playlist
we have more chats like this along with
other videos about guns
perks maps and more thanks for watching
[Music]
you